welcome to scc 208 shared fate
in this talk you'll learn how google
cloud is working to enable you to move
from a shared responsibility model for
security in public cloud to a shared
fate model where we as the cloud
provider
collaborate much more strongly with you
and take additional responsibility for
making sure what's deployed together is
in the most secure and compliant state
a core component of this ability to
change how risk is transferred is
providing you with production proven
blueprints
for
foundational infrastructure workloads
and applications built with google cloud
best practices and patterns so that
collectively we have a much better view
and understanding of the quantified risk
and the security posture being deployed
i'm andy chang senior product manager
for the cloud security team
as we've seen with many customers
an ongoing desire is to get started and
operate much quicker but with also
additional security so that the value of
cloud can reflect in the businesses that
you run
the approach we're now taking to enable
and accelerate this is building out a
set of opinionated security foundation
and posture blueprints to automatically
allow you to leverage predefined google
cloud security best practices for your
infrastructure and for your workloads
this is part of the overall google cloud
vision
in security for going even further in
our partnership with our customers we
want to move at the industry and help
move the industry from current shared
responsibility approach to a shared fate
model where we're truly partners in your
success and you in achieving your goals
and this won't happen overnight but the
key pieces are coming into place
first a necessary condition for this is
that the underlying cloud infrastructure
is highly trusted and secure
that we're providing you with that
secure compliant platform as well as a
portfolio of security and compliance
products and solutions that you can use
the good news is that in our commission
to make google the most trusted cloud
we're well along the way there
next we're providing customers with
opinionated foundational and posture
blueprints matched to the type of
workloads that they need which enable
you again to build on top of the
underlying services to stack and build
posture blueprints on top of planning
zones and which all have google best
practices in terms of configurations
architecture security posture embed with
them
you're therefore able to stack these
opinionated posture blueprints on top of
landing zones and take advantage of the
knowledge that google's already built
around security
we then take the next step and think
about taking the blueprints as the basis
for end end solutions to solve very
specific business process problems
for example web application api
protections serial trust and beyond corp
enterprise solutions and security
analytics at scale
by combining these
together you're now able to get the best
practices in a deployable form
targeted towards solving very specific
business problems
finally
by
having the combination of the blueprints
and the solutions it leads to a
significant increase in the ability for
you to use consistent approved and then
patterns for complete business processes
and applications
that consistency and greater
default secure configuration and best
practice adoption leads to a much more
quantified risk model
allows us and you to better understand
the architecture and risks of being
deployed in your infrastructure in your
workloads and therefore allows us to
take on more responsibility
collaborating with you enabling
different models of risk transfer as we
launched both our risk manager and a
risk protection program this allows you
if you've adopted these patterns to take
advantage of some specific cyber
insurance offerings
which will allow you to now have more
options for that risk transfer and risk
management
along the evolution path of shared fate
in addition to changing how you as
customers can manage risk we see
parallel transformation opportunities in
other key tracks as well today many
customers in public cloud have complex
experiences for security and governance
and we see an opportunity for the use
the jobs to be done framework to change
these into much more consistent and
complete end-to-end journeys
similarly many customers in public cloud
have disjoint experiences managing
policy and governance for both their
individual instances in public cloud as
well as across public cloud and on-prem
we feel again that there is an
opportunity to change
this fundamentally into a much more
coordinated and verifiable experience
blueprints play a key role both in
moving
product security from a bolted on after
effect to a built-in part of the
underlying solution and also from moving
platform security from a set of complex
configurations to increasingly secure by
default
as we think about this stack from a
customer perspective
as we talked about we first build on top
of that secure core google
infrastructure and with the next layer
of security products like scc premium
assured workloads organization policy vp
service controls giving you
additional capabilities differentiated
their ability to help you manage your
security posture your visibility and
your segmentation
these form the lowest layer of the
security stack on top of this baseline
comes both the foundational and posture
blueprints where the foundational
blueprints include org policy resource
hierarchy networking access segmentation
logging detective controls
to allow you to take advantage of proven
designs to build your foundational
infrastructure and on top of that the
posture blueprints cover specific sets
of services aggregated together and both
the individual service specific controls
as well as the interest services
controls necessary for the workloads to
work properly
the blueprints come in three tiers and
they differ really in their level of
native support and their life cycle
management
the three tiers are supported blueprints
verified blueprints and compatible
blueprints supported blueprints are
created by google security teams and
managed as products with regulars
six-month refreshes and attestation and
testing of the functionality and
resilience as well as the
interoperability testing between them
verified blueprints can be created by
google teams partner teams or customers
the key is that the lifecycle management
as well as the at the station for fit
for purpose are the responsibility of
the creating team
compatible blueprints are just that
they're compatible meaning they can be
created by anyone and their requirement
is that they need to be from a format
and also a style standpoint
correctly matched to
be operated with our blueprint tools and
a blueprint engine
and finally on top of the posture
blueprints we have security solutions
and these solutions address specific use
cases and further add the wrappings of
go to market collateral best practice
application notes so that you can adopt
these for your particular use cases
we focus today really on the security
foundation's blueprints as well as the
security posture blueprints and their
relationship to each other
we think about the core foundational
blueprint the key is to allow you to
start up front with best practices
embedded in it creates a better starting
point as well for security and
compliance as the security best
practices encoded in our foundation
blueprint give you a great start to
being compatible and meeting certain
requirements within cis pci dss nist 853
as well as iso 2701
in addition they allow you to implement
key security best practices and
philosophies according how google
protects itself
these key principles really fall into
three categories
first that all defense is always
executed at in depth and at scale so
multiple layers of protection separate
something of interest from a potential
external threat
they allow you to adopt the beyond prod
model for
deployment centric infrastructure
and the ability to have a zero trust
model around both the infrastructure you
build as well as the applications you
build
and then also they risk the cloud
deployment and adoption by moving you to
these proven patterns that allow you to
have move towards a more shared fate
relationship between yourselves and
google
to dive in a little bit more detail on
the security foundation's blueprint it
provides that starts a strong starting
point we talked about in baseline it's
delivered not only in documentation but
infrastructure as code and deployable
terraform that automates accelerates
your ability to use it
it encodes those best practices and can
be deployed either at an organization
level or a folder level
and it has a six month life cycle
refresh we deployed the very first
version back in august 2020
the second version was deployed in april
of this year and then v3 will be
launching in october
and the posture blueprints that we'll
talk about build on top of it are tested
and verified against
it one example of the security posture
blueprint is the one we're building for
secured data warehousing
secure data analytics and
data warehousing are a key reason many
customers come to google as we're
differentiated in our bigquery product
and the things we do in data analytics
as you can see here you've adopted an
architecture that has the landing area
and ingest the data warehouse itself the
storage and processing
classification and governance pieces as
well as security posture and detection
for threats
in addition there's also the optional
presentation layer which in the case of
the blueprints we've built we provide an
example in the form of an ai notebook
to dive this a little bit more detail
what you see in the next level detail of
the architecture is we've segmented this
into four different projects
within the bigquery data routes itself
and then separate set of projects for
the ai
notebook these projects not only create
resource separation
but are also their own vpc service
perimeters which allow us to manage both
sensitive and non-sensitive data
the ingest contains the ability to just
both batch and streaming data and then
de-identification of all the data so
they can be correctly classified into
the non-sensitive and sensitive areas of
bigquery we manage the im structures the
data encryption
and also data classification so that
using data catalog you can have column
level access control of the bigquery
data warehouse and this architecture is
based on
proven production instances we've built
together with some of our financial
service customers
so that we have good confidence that
this scales and works well for those
regulated industries
if we dive into a little bit more what
is in the
bigquery data warehouse blueprint in
addition to the terraform itself and
deployable instances it has a set of
documentation that comes with it around
and accessible through either the
architecture center or the best practice
site
quick starts technical design docs
solution guides
the code itself with the guide for
deployment of the code terraform code
overview decks
licensing and pricing models
public talks the blogs and also
application notes for specific use cases
as examples to get you started quick
more quickly
it two is on a six month refresh cycle
with the first version just being
launched here in october and then the v2
targeted for a q2 2022 launch
built on top and also available as
standalone what this means is that with
each of the posture blueprints they are
first and foremost able to be compatible
with our security foundation's blueprint
and tested i get from an integration
standpoint with that and the other
posture blueprints but also they're
deployable and standalone in your own
brownfield
and then they include third-party
assistations around the security
architecture design
the stride threat modeling as well as
being pen tested and you'll see with
this blueprint in q4 being tested
against nist 853 compliance standard in
detail
we think about the controls that are
fundamentally built into the bigquery
data warehouse they fall in three
categories controls that manage
configuration state
as mis configuration is one of the
largest sources of data breaches we
particularly provide encode best
practices for configuration of each of
the services
as well as the integration and
interaction of the services within the
bigquery
secure data warehouse blueprint
behavioral controls focus specifically
around the design and architecture of
the secure data warehouse to look at
specific threats from
either data exfiltration
from privilege escalation from things
that break the segmentation model that
built in and then environmental controls
as we talked about before
the
secure data warehouse blueprint can be
deployed either as a standalone in which
case the environmental controls are
fully encased with that particular
blueprint or if they're deployed on top
of a security foundation's blueprint
they inherit the environmental controls
from the underlying core infrastructure
we're now going to move to a demo we're
going to walk you through a fully
deployed secure data warehouse and
highlight some of the configuration
controls the behavioral
security protections as well as the
environmental controls
here we have a demo organization in
which we've deployed the secured data
warehouse blueprint in its own folder
the secured data warehouse blueprint
consists of four distinct projects
a data ingestion project which includes
cloud storage pub sub and data flow
a data lake project which includes the
bigquery instance for non-sensitive data
a privileged bigquery data warehouse
which includes cloud storage as well as
the privileged bigquery data rails
instance
and a data governance project which
includes data catalog
key and key management
and
data classification through dlp
when deploying these into your own
brownfield or on top of the foundation's
blueprint you can plug in the data
encryption keys into your existing
encryption key project logging into your
centralized lodging project and the
network connections to allow the data
flow templates in to your existing
system
you can also run this standalone if you
want to experiment and play with it and
to do that we include two harness
projects which supply the data flow
template and the terraform sourcing
the security perimeters around the data
bigquery data warehouse
and the other projects are set up as
follows we have three separate
perimeters one around ingestion one
around the privileged data and then one
around data governance
in addition we set up bridges between
ingestion and governance privilege and
governance and then privilege and
ingestion
if we look at the
vpc service printer around data gesture
you'll see it includes the ingestion
project and the data lake
has its own defined access context
levels and specific egress rules
similarly if we look at the vp service
printer around privileged data it
captures the privileged
bigquery data warehouse project
has its own access levels defined and
egress rules
and then the last perimeter is around
data governance which
secures the data governance project
and has its own access levels defined
if we look at the bridging
the first bridge connects the ingestion
the data lake and governance
the second bridge connects the data lake
to the privileged
and then the final bridge connects the
data governance to privileged
as you can see we've defined access
policies for each of the separate vpc
service monitors
we've also used our dlp
to de-identify specifically card number
and card pin data
so that in the non-sensitive bigquery
instance they can be used
by lower access levels and folks with
more generalized roles separate from
when they're the actual values are being
used in the privileged
data warehouse
we use data catalog with policy tags in
order to further provide column level
control
you can see we use
column level policy tags for person name
credit limit and also credit card number
so we give you additional fine grain
control of who what service accounts
with humans can access these pieces of
sensitive data as an example
if we now look at the datatate lake
which has the non-sensitive data set
you can see that if we look at
again card number
and card pin
and create a query
you see de-identified version of both
card pin and card number that is still
format preserving
if we now move to the sensitive data in
the privileged data warehouse
if we were to look at
the card pin data
because i have the right set of accesses
you'll see the actual card pin data
within the privileged and protected
bigquery instance
however to show you that we're using
column level
control i'm now also going to try to
query the card number
here you see access has been denied
because this particular user currently
does not have the
im permissions to access the card
numbers
we can fix this
by going back
and granting
the
permissions for fine grain reader on
that particular column
and now if we rerun the query
you'll see we got the both the
pin and the underlying card numbers
so we've now shown you the architecture
example for the secure data warehouse
containing three vpc service perimeters
and both data lake for non-sensitive
data and a separate secure data set
which has
column level access managed through data
catalog policy text
we've now shown you a deployed version
of the secure data warehouse blueprint
and we walked you through some of the
key configuration behavioral and
environmental controls so hopefully this
provides you a view of how we're
embedding best practices and security as
well as the architecture to give you
something as a reference starting point
in pattern to jump start your workloads
in production around data warehousing
and data analytics
to learn more you can explore at
cloud.google.com security desk best
practices the range of our current
portfolio of blueprints for foundation
and for security posture
explore the documentation as well as the
terraform repo that we've supplied and
then download kind of reference guides
from step-by-step basis
we'd highly encourage you to deploy
these security blueprints into your own
example organizations and folders so
that you can experiment to see how they
fit with your environments and
definitely encourage you to customize
and use the modules of script if they
create additional differentiation for
the pure particular needs
as we talked about these blueprints are
refreshed on a six-month cycle so we
highly encourage you to also feedback to
us where you've seen gaps and things
that you'd want to see in future
iterations we can put that in the
backlog and
many of your needs may show up in future
versions of the blueprint so you can use
a standard blueprint as opposed to one
that you've branched yourself
and lastly we encourage you to start
trialing the security command center
premium as it provides an overall cloud
security posture management around not
only your organization but these
multi-project and folder-centric posture
blueprints as well
thank you so much for your time and the
opportunity to share with you what we're
thinking about on the shared fate
standpoint as well as some of those core
blueprints that allow you to jumpstart
and get started with the best practices
and patterns that can help you be more
successful